CHRIS DIBONA: Hello, everyone.
My name's Chris DiBona.
I help out Cliff sometimes with
the Authors at Google Program.
So today we have
John Scalzi here
to talk to us about
"Lock In" book things.
JOHN SCALZI: Yeah, book
things, book things.
CHRIS DIBONA: Next week, we have
some really terrific guests,
too, but this week is John.
JOHN SCALZI: Right.
CHRIS DIBONA: So
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
JOHN SCALZI: I'm here
all week, try the veal.
CHRIS DIBONA: Try the veal.
You might remember
John for his time
as an AOL employee--
writing for an AOL sub-site.
Which one was it?
JOHN SCALZI: A little
humor area called "howdy."
CHRIS DIBONA: Slash, howdy?
JOHN SCALZI: Yeah, actually,
you would click on the triangle
when you signed into AOL at
your lightning fast 28k VOD.
Yeah.
And you click on that
and it would pop up
a cartoon or an essay
or something like that.
CHRIS DIBONA: So the
interface-- the gateway--
was like a triangle.
JOHN SCALZI: Yeah, the
gateway was a triangle.
CHRIS DIBONA: And everyone knew
that the triangle meant funny.
JOHN SCALZI: Right, that's
exactly how it worked.
CHRIS DIBONA: This is
how the internet was
before the internet,
just for the record.
JOHN SCALZI: Good times.
Good times.
CHRIS DIBONA: You didn't
have your own go link on--
JOHN SCALZI: Well, no, I did.
I did.
You "Go Scalzi."
CHRIS DIBONA: "Go Scalzi."
Oh, that's nice.
It's not the end of the world
if I tell the world this.
Our internal
system, all the time
we're telling people to go
slash here, goes slash there.
And so, you were "Go,
Slash, Scalzi Live"
was the link for
this particular talk.
I'm going to get off
stage and let you start.
What we're going
to do is, John's
going to speak about some of
his wanted works of literature.
And then we'll be
taking some Q and A.
So you'll have ample time
to ask some questions.
And then we'll have a
signing in the back.
JOHN SCALZI: Sounds good.
CHRIS DIBONA: There you go.
And so everyone, John Scalzi.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN SCALZI: One, thank
you for having me.
The last time I was
here is 2007 when
"The Last Colony"
was coming out.
And as Chris
mentioned, at the time,
my publisher was suing Google.
So that wasn't awkward at all.
But now I think things have
been reasonably well settled,
and I think we'll be
moving on just fine.
I have to say again,
it's always a lot of fun
for me to come back to Google.
Because he was mentioning that I
was at AOL when AOL was Google,
you know, back in the 1990s.
So every once in a
while, I come around
to the campus with all the
cafes, and the pet care,
and the masseuses, and
all that sort of stuff.
And it's like, all I'm
missing is "Third Eye Blind"
and it would be just
like I was there again.
I can understand if that doesn't
go over particularly well here,
because you guys remember
what happened to AOL.
Not going to happen to you.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
It's totally not
going to happen.
So the new book that I have
out is called "Lock In".
This is the book, which
obviously quite a few of you
have.
I'm going to read a
little bit from it.
I'm going to tell you
a little bit about it
before I do the reading,
which is that as you know,
technology is a really
interesting thing.
And you can do many
things with technology.
And some of them can be
awesome and some of them
can be troublesome.
You know, you
experience it even with,
like, some of the Google
products that you have.
On one sense, there are people
who love the fact that, like, I
can go to Google
Earth or Google Maps
and actually find a
picture of my house.
I think that's really awesome.
I also think that Google
needs to go and redo it,
because the picture
you took, my lawn
is yellow because it
was like early March.
And my trash can is tipped
over in front of my house.
This is not how I want
the world to see my house,
so please, Google
Maps, go fix that.
But some people
think it's awesome.
On the other hand,
there are some people
who feel that all this is
somehow an invasion of privacy.
I think in Europe,
they had some people
who were like there's some
places where they don't want
you to map or
something like that.
The folks over here with
Google Glass-- in one sense,
it's awesome that you can
walk around and actually
have that stuff without having
your phone directly in front
of you, and therefore,
walking into trees.
On the other hand, there are
some people who are like,
will you please turn
those things off?
Because they don't know if
you are running the pictures
live or not.
So there's always that back and
forth about what technology is
and how we integrated
it into our lives.
And it's really interesting
to me, quite frankly,
just how quickly you get
used to how technology just
is integral to your life.
Like my Google phone
here from Motorola,
which you dearly departed.
And so, the thing that is
awesome about this piece
of technology is not that I
can talk to it and say, "Hey,
Google Now,"-- turn that
off-- and have it respond.
And I will ask it a question
and it will give me an answer.
What is awesome is that I
can say, "Hey, Google Now,"
and ask it a question
and give me an answer,
and if it gets it
wrong, I get annoyed.
Right?
And what that means is--
why that's so cool--
is that I'm so
used to this being
an integral part of my life-- of
living in the future, of having
the entire world
at my doorstep--
that frankly, when the
technology does not
work the way it's supposed
to that I can get annoyed.
That the wonder of all
this technology, the wonder
of everything that science
has wrought and that you guys
work on on a day
in, day out basis
will just piss me off when
it's not working exactly
the way it's supposed to.
That means we are
living in the future
because it is just part
of our everyday lives.
And "Lock In" is about that.
What happens is that the day
after tomorrow, as they say,
there is a new disease that's
sweeps around the world.
And so, let's say
everybody in this room
gets sick with this disease.
At first, it's like a flu.
So you all get sick, right?
About, let's say, everybody
but the first three rows
here gets better.
You get sick, you get
better, it's the flu.
Not a problem.
But these folks in
the first three rows,
you get to the second
phase of the disease.
And what that is like
viral meningitis.
And your brain swells up
and it's really painful.
And then some of you drop dead.
Let's say--
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Those folks, sorry, you're dead.
And these folks are still alive.
And of these folks
who are still alive,
there is a third stage,
which is called lock in.
And lock in means that your
entire autonomic system
breaks down.
Your brain is still
functioning but you are not
able to do anything.
You are literally locked
inside of your body.
And so, it's about
1% of the people.
So you and you.
You are locked in.
Sorry, Chris.
And so, in one sort
of sense, it doesn't
seem like that many
people altogether.
But if it's these two in a
room of 200 people replicated
all across the
country, that ends up
being 1% of the population
maybe like at the time.
Let's say about
4.35 million people,
which is the city of Los Angeles
or the state of Connecticut.
And then, all of the sudden, it
becomes this huge public health
crisis.
And how do we solve it?
How do we get them
out of their minds,
so to speak, in a
very literal sense?
And the answer is--
and this is something
the folks here at Google would
know-- is you throw technology
at it and also a lot of money.
And so there's this
research initiative that
includes brain prosthesis,
you know neural networks
within your brain--
integrating with your brain--
a multiple online place for
the people who are locked in
to have some semblance
of conversation
amongst each other,
and then these things
called Threeps-- which are
named after C3PO-- that they
are basically androids that they
drive around with their brains.
So Chris is locked in, but
he will have this really cool
looking android--
ironically enough--
and he will wander around
and do all the stuff
that he does in the android
while his body is at home being
tended to.
And the thing is, is when
it first happens, of course,
it's the most amazing thing.
We've turned you
into an android.
25 years on-- which is
when this happens-- nobody
cares that you're
an android anymore,
you're just part of the world.
1% of everybody in the
world is an android.
And how do you deal with that
and where do you go from there?
So that was interesting to me.
The thing that interests
me about technology
is not how awesome
the technology is.
It is what happens after
the awesome wears out.
You know, when it just becomes
part of your day-to-day life
and you deal with this stuff
and it's not that big of a deal.
And the most that you
think about your technology
is when it's not doing
what it's supposed to do.
And to give an idea
of kind of what
that would be like to be someone
who is dealing with this stuff,
I'm going to read a quick
chapter from chapter five
where our protagonist,
Chris Shane,
is looking for an apartment.
Chris is someone
who is a Haden-- who
is one of these people
who is locked in--
and so when Chris is
looking for someplace,
it has to be some place
that actually caters
to the needs of someone
who is locked in.
So I'm going to go ahead
and read from that.
And just so you know, Chris
is part of a famous family.
So Chris would be
very much like someone
who is like a child
star at one point
and stops being that
child star and tries
to have a normal life.
And right now Chris works
for the FBI, first couple
days on the job, he's trying
to get a new apartment in DC.
The Realtor was a small, elegant
woman named LaTasha Robinson,
and she met me directly
outside the Bureau building.
One of her Realty specialties
was the Haden market,
so the Bureau connected
me with her to help me
find an apartment.
Given her clientele, the
chances that she might not
know who I was were close
to nil, a suspicion that
was verified as I approached.
She smiled the
smile I recognized
from years of being trotted out
as the official Haden's poster
child, part of the official
Haden's poster family.
I didn't hold it against her.
"Agent Shane," she said,
holding out her hand.
"Really lovely to meet you."
I took the hand and shook
it. "Ms. Robinson, likewise."
"I'm sorry.
This is just kind of
exciting," she said.
"I don't need that
many famous people,
I mean, who aren't
politicians."--
This takes place in DC--
"Not in this town,
no," I agreed.
"And I don't think of
politicians as being famous,
do you?
They're just politicians."
"I couldn't agree more."
"My car's right over
here," she said,
pointing to a relatively
unflashy Cadillac parked
where it would get ticketed.
"Why don't we get started?"
I got into the passenger side.
Robinson got into the driver's
seat and pulled out her tablet.
"Amble," she said,
and the car slid out
from the curve
just ahead, I noted
as I glanced in the rear-view
mirror, of a traffic cop.
We headed east on
Pennsylvania Avenue.
"The car's just going to
drive around for a few minutes
while we get set
up here," Robinson
said, tapping her tablet.
For all her gushing
a few seconds before,
she slipped into business
mode pretty quickly.
"I've got your basic request
list and personal information."
She looked over as
if to acknowledge
that I was, in fact, a
Haden and she knew it.
"So let's get a few things
narrowed down before we start."
"All right," I said.
"So how close do you
want to be to work?"
"Closer is better."
"Are we talking walking-close
or Metro line-close?"
"Metro line-close
is fine," I said.
"Do you prefer a
neighborhood that's
hip or one that's quiet?"
"It doesn't really
matter to me."
"You say that now,
but if I get you
an apartment over a bar in
Adams Morgan and you hate it,
you're going to
blame me," Robinson
said looking over at me.
"I promise, noise isn't
going to bother me,"
I said. "I can turn
down my hearing."
"Do you plan on using the
apartment to socialize?"
"Not really," I said. "I do most
of my socializing elsewhere.
I might have a friend
over from time to time."
Robinson looked
over again at this
and seemed to be
considering whether to ask
for clarification and
decided against it.
It was a fair call.
There were Threep
fetishists out there.
They weren't really my
thing, I have to say.
"Will your body be physically
present, and if so,
will you need room for
a caretaker?" she asked.
"My body and its care-taking are
already squared away," I said.
"We won't be needing
space for either, at least
not right away."
"In that case, I have some
Haden efficiency flats
on my availability
list," she said.
"Would you like to see those?"
"Are they worth my time?"
I asked.
Robinson shrugged.
"Some Hadens like
them," she said.
"I think they're a little
small, but then, they're
not designed for non-Hadens."
"Are they close by?"
"I've got a building of them
on D Avenue in Southwest,
right by Federal Center
Metro," Robinson said.
"The Department of
Health and Human Services
hires a lot of Hadens, so it's
convenient housing for them."
"All right," I said. "We
might as well check them out."
"We'll go there first," Robinson
said, and spoke the address
to the Cadillac.
Five minutes later,
we were in front
of a depressing slab
of anonymous brutalist
architecture.
"This is lovely," I said dryly.
"I think it used to be a
government office building,"
Robinson said. "They converted
it about 20 years ago.
It was one of the first
buildings redesigned
with Hadens in mind."
She nodded me into the lobby,
which was clean and plain.
A Threep receptionist
sat behind a desk.
The Threep was set
to transmit ID data
over the common channel.
In my field of vision,
it's owner's data
popped up above
the Threeps head--
Genevieve Tourneaux,
27 years old, native
of Rockville, Maryland.
Her public address
for direct messages.
"Hello," Robinson
said to Genevieve,
and showed her her Realtors ID.
"We're here to look at the
vacancy on the fifth floor."
Genevieve turned to me
and I realized belatedly
that I didn't have my
own personal data out
on the common channel.
Some Hadens found that rude.
I quickly popped it up.
She gave me a quick nod
as if an acknowledgement,
did a small double-take,
then recovered
and turned her
attention to Robinson.
"Unit 503 is unlocked for the
next 15 minutes," she said.
"Thank you," Robinson said
and nodded over to me.
"Hold on a second," I said.
I turned back to Genevieve.
"May I have guest access to
the building channel, please?"
Genevieve nodded to me and I
saw the channel marker pop up
in my field of view.
I connected to it.
The lobby walls
exploded into signage.
Some of the notes were your
basic cork board notes-- people
looking for roommates
or to sublet
or asking after lost pets.
At the moment, however, signs
about the walk-out in March
dominated.
Signs reminding
tenants to stay home,
plans for walk-out
activities, requests
to let Hadens coming
into town for the march
crash in apartments with
the sardonic notation
that they would not
need much space.
"Is everything OK?"
Robinson asked.
"It's fine," I said.
"I'm just taking in the
posters on the wall."
I read a few more and
then we walked over
to the elevator bank and took
the lift up to the fifth floor.
"Extra large elevators,"
Robinson noted as we rose.
"Hydraulic lift.
Makes it easier to bring
bodies up to the room."
"I thought these were all
efficiency apartments," I said.
"No, not all of
them," Robinson said.
"Some of them are full-sized and
have dedicated medical suites
and caretaker rooms.
Even the efficiencies
have cradle hookups.
They're supposed to be
used on a temp basis,
although I hear some Hadens
are using them full time now."
"And why is that?"
The elevator stopped
and the doors opened.
"Abrams Kettering"-- which is
a bill that has been passed
that will cut government
funding for Hadens research
and medical services--
"Adams Kettering,"
Robinson said.
She walked out of the
lift and down the hall.
"Assistance is getting
slashed so a lot of Hadens
are downsizing.
Those in town homes are moving
into smaller apartments.
Those in apartments are
moving into efficiencies.
And some of those
in efficiencies
are taking on roommates.
They're using the
chargers in shifts."
She glanced back
to me and her eyes
flickered over my shiny,
expensive Threep as if to say,
not that you have
to worry about that.
"It's been bad for the
market, to be honest.
But that's good for you
as a potential renter.
Now you have a lot more
options a lot cheaper."
She stopped at apartment 503.
"That is if this
doesn't bowl you over."
She opened the door and stood
aside to let me pass through.
Haden efficiency apartment 503
was two meters by three meters
and entirely bare save for
one built-in counter top.
I stepped inside and
immediately got claustrophobia.
"This isn't an apartment,
it's a closet,"
I said, stepping forward
to let Robinson in.
"I usually think of
it as a bathroom"
Robinson said, and pointed
to a small tiled area which
had a bank of electrical outlets
and a couple of covered drains
on the floor flush
with the tile.
"That would be the
medical nook, by the way.
Right where the
toilet would be."
"You're not exactly
giving me the hard sell
on this apartment,
Ms Robinson," I said.
"Well, to be fair, if
all you're looking to do
is park your Threep every
night, this isn't a bad choice,"
Robinson said.
She pointed to the
back right corner,
where the grooves and
high voltage outlets
were set into the wall ready
to receive inductive chargers.
"It's designed with
standard Threep cradles
in mind and the hard wired
and wireless networks
are fast and have
deep throughput.
The spaces have been
designed with Threeps in mind
so you don't have
inessential things taking up
space like closets or sinks.
It's everything you need and
absolutely nothing you don't."
"I hate it," I said.
"I thought you
might," Robinson said.
"That's why I showed
it to you first.
Now that we have
that out of the way,
we can show you something
that you might actually
be interested in."
I stared back at
the spot of tile
and thought about
putting a human body
there more or less permanently.
"So these kind of apartments
are hot right now?"
I asked.
"They are," Robinson said. "I
don't usually deal with them.
Not enough commission on them.
They usually get rented
through online want ads,
but yes, right now,
this kind of apartment
is selling like hotcakes."
"Well, now I'm feeling a
little depressed," I said.
"Well, you don't have to feel
depressed," Robinson said.
"You're not going to live here.
You're not going to
have your body in here."
"But apparently some
people are," I said.
"Yes," Robinson said.
"Maybe it's a blessing that
the bodies don't notice."
"Ah, but that's
not true," I said.
"We're locked in, but
we're not unconscious.
Trust me, Ms Robinson, we
notice where our bodies are.
We notice it every
moment we're awake."
All right, so that's that.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
And like I said,
one of the things
that you can see from
that particular thing
is this is someone who is just
trying to find an apartment.
But an apartment that conforms
to the reality of their life
situation.
That there is an
android that they
will use to get around
in the real world,
but there needs to be
a space for the body.
And that body will need to have
a caretaker looking after it
while the owner of the
body is, literally,
somewhere else in the world.
And like I said, on
a day-to-day basis,
this is just the life they lead.
For us reading a book about
the future, this is all new
and this is all cool, right?
But one of the things you
have to really do as a writer,
you really want to try to avoid
is making a big deal out of it
for the people who
are living in there.
One of the things that
science fiction does
really badly is the
exposition trap,
which is the "As you know, Bob."
Where you go, you
know, "As you know,
Chris, we are here at Google,
this worldwide technological
company that was founded on
the search engine thing."
and you'd be like,
"Oh, yes, absolutely."
He knows that.
He's been working
here for 10 years.
But in fiction, you
see a lot of that
because the audience
doesn't know that.
You have to give that
information while
at the same time
respecting the fact
that the characters that you are
following and creating actually
have all of this internalized.
One of the defining challenges
of writing science fiction
is to establish for the
reader in the present time
this awesome technology while
at the same time establishing
for the characters who
live in that future
that this is their life.
Right?
That this magnificent
technology is
no more exciting to them as
than a cellphone or a DVR,
which both of which,
if you think about it,
are pretty damn awesome.
If I went back 25 years ago
and told the 20-year-old me
about a cellphone, I would
be like, "Are you a wizard?"
You know?
You Think about it-- remember
Star Trek, the original Star
Trek, where Kirk's
got a communicator.
And you're like, oh,
so it only does voice.
That's cute.
Because it's like my phone
here does voice, it does text,
it takes pictures, it
does-- it's basically,
you can use it now
as a tricorder.
Quite frankly, if you've got
one of those Google Gear things
that's got, you can
check your heart rate,
you can see what's
going on with your body.
And so that communicator
that Kirk had back in 1967,
but supposedly the 23rd century,
is just unbelievably quaint.
So it's just a fascinating thing
about how the future catches up
with you and how, as a
science fiction writer,
you deal with that.
So what I'm trying to say
is that, when you read this,
I hope what you get out of it
is that this feature is cool.
But for them, it's
just another day
with a whole different
set of problems.
We are, I think, about
at the half hour point,
which means that it's time to
actually open up to questions
from you folks here at Google.
And I'll be happy to
talk about "Lock In."
I'll be happy to talk about
the other books that I have.
I'll be happy to talk
about the TV series that
are being developed
out of a couple
of my books or the video game.
My personal life, my website,
you can ask anything.
I will answer any
question you have.
Sometimes the answer will be,
I can't believe you asked that.
Leave and never come back.
But as long as we're clear
on that, then we're good.
So let's go ahead.
CHRIS DIBONA: Can you
mention your appearance?
JOHN SCALZI: Oh, I also
did want to mention.
I do have an appearance
tonight at Books Incorporated
in Mountain View.
I will be doing a reading there.
I will not be
doing this reading.
I'll be doing an entirely
different reading,
so it will be an all new
show as far as it goes.
If you're not doing
anything tonight, come out.
It starts at 7:00.
Bring yourself and every
single person you've ever met.
All right, so first question.
AUDIENCE: Specifically in
the "Old Man's War" series,
something that I
noticed in your writing
that I don't see in
a lot of other places
is that you portray
people who are married
or have been married
for a long time,
longstanding
relationships as opposed
to simply the chase portion.
This seems-- I don't want
to say unique in fiction,
but pretty rare.
What brought you to do that, and
why you and pretty much nobody
else.
JOHN SCALZI: I don't know
that I would necessarily
agree with that particular
premise, because for example,
in "Forever War", there is
a longstanding relationship
between the protagonist
and Mary Gay
who, interestingly enough,
has a very near name
of Joe Holdeman's wife, Gay.
And so, for me
also-- I mean, I've
been married for a certain
number of years, going up
on 20 years now.
My wife is, actually, the
template for Jane Sagan.
Right?
So when you imagine Jane Sagan,
imagine a woman who's about
5'10", straight,
brown hair, you know,
and will kill you if
you get in her way.
Because that is my wife.
She is no-nonsense, super
awesome, and when it came to,
I need to develop this
bad ass character,
here's who I will use.
But the simple
fact of the matter
is that being married or
being in relationships
and having those long term
relationships are part of life.
And that they are a
significant portion of it.
And almost everybody
has those relationships.
If you're not showing
those, then you
are not accurately
reflecting life.
And people are like, well,
it's science fiction,
you don't really have to
accurately reflect life.
Which is a rotten lie.
I mean, you can actually
talk about the future
and you can speculate and
you can do whatever you want.
But at the end of the day, the
human creature is important.
We have all this technology
now that's amazing.
We'll have all this
technology in the future.
Humans are the same build that
they were 30,000 years ago,
as far as it goes.
So not having those things
that humans do in your books,
eventually, it makes
it feel artificial.
It was also really
important from the point
of view of that particular
character, John Perry,
to establish some of what
he was leaving behind.
So much of who he was was about
who he was with that someone
else-- with his wife.
And so it made leaving the
earth that much more, because he
was leaving that aspect of his
life behind or so he thought.
The other thing
is that also when
you write a military
science fiction
book like I did
with guns and lasers
and explosions and aliens
who want to eat you
and all that sort of stuff, you
have a really good opportunity
to lose like three-quarters
of your audience
right away if you start
off with a scene, you know,
where Hunky McChesty
starts shooting
the aliens with his big zapper
gun and all that sort of stuff
and it's just blood,
blood, blood, blood.
I wanted to show--
I intentionally
did the first scene of
this action-adventure story
with a guy missing his wife.
Because that is something
everybody-- anybody who's
been in a relationship, can you
think about losing your spouse
or losing your longtime partner?
It just rips your heart out.
I mean, I'm getting kind of
choked up thinking about it.
And so, everybody has that
moment that all of the sudden,
you're thrown in, you
understand this guy.
And you will follow
his story because you
know how much he
misses his wife.
So that was part
the reason to do it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm enjoying a lot of
your books as audiobooks.
And many of them are
ready by Will Wheaton,
you guys make a great team.
So with "Lock In," you're
trying something a little bit
difference, where you have two
versions of the audio book--
one read by Will and
another one ready by Amber--
I forgot her last name, Benton.
And I'm only a couple hours in.
And so far, I think if
I hadn't known about it,
it wouldn't even
have occurred to me
that the character could be
anything other than male.
So great job there.
But I think I still need a
little bit more convincing.
So like, once I'm finished
with the Will Wheaton version,
why should I listen
to the other one?
JOHN SCALZI: Because
it's awesome.
Because it's awesome.
Because Amber did
a fantastic job.
And that, Amber's
way of doing Chris
is different than Will's
way of doing Chris.
And both of those
ways of doing Chrises
are slightly different
than my way of doing Chris.
You're right, when I originally
wrote Chris and in the book,
Chris nowhere in
there is gendered.
And there's a reason for that.
Part of it is because
I wanted to see
where people assigned Chris.
What are your defaults
as a human being?
And the answer is,
you'll find out,
by how you respond to Chris.
My wife read Chris and I did the
thing-- because I automatically
just sort of, when I'm
talking about people
in a nonspecific way, just sort
of automatically gender male
because that's what we do.
And that's what I
got brought up with.
Literally, the style guide for
AP and Chicago and everyone
else said, when in
doubt, gender male.
So I will still slip into that.
And one time, I slipped
in that with Chris.
And she's was like, what?
No.
Chris is emphatically
female for her.
For other people, Chris
is emphatically male.
What it comes down
to is, really,
what your own reading
comes out of it.
And I put that in
there for the purpose
of making it interesting,
making it kind of exciting.
But I also didn't
tell people about it.
It's coming out
now because people
are like-- thousands of
people have read the book now
and they're like,
hey, I was confused.
I need guidance.
And I'm not offering
any sort of guidance.
When I wrote Chris, I
specifically was like,
I'm not going to go there.
Chris could be male.
Chris could be female.
Chris could be intersex.
Chris could be trans--
started one, went the other,
maybe went the other direction.
Maybe Chris has decided
that gender is not a thing
to be considered at
all, that it's not
necessary in the construct
that Chris exists in.
Because Chris is a
Threep to most people.
And in the Agora, which
is the online world
that the Hadens are, you can
be anybody who you want to be.
So this is essentialism
towards gender
is not necessarily a construct
that works in the same way
as it works in the
physical world.
So when it comes
down to the readings
that Will and Amber
did, they both read
from their gender
essentialist point of view.
And so it's really
interesting for me
to get the back and forth.
And I say you should listen to
Amber's-- aside from her doing
a fantastic job-- to see how
you respond to Chris making that
switch.
You know?
Does it change
the story for you?
Does it change the power
dynamic between Chris and them?
dynamic between Chris
and the other people that
Chris associates with?
And the answer is,
that will be up to you.
Again, you don't want to hit
people over the head with it.
Like I said, I didn't
mention it at all
until other people
started to mention it.
Because I didn't want it to
get in the way of the story.
I wanted it to be the
thing that you noticed
after you were
done with a story.
Like, that story was cool,
Chris is-- what is Chris?
Oh, shit.
You know?
And then it kind of blows your
mind and you go off from there.
So yeah, listen to
Amber and see how
it changes the main
character for you.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: So as
someone named Amber,
it's a little bit awkward
following that up.
JOHN SCALZI: You
did a great job.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I work with the
social group here at Google,
which among other
things, we run Google+.
And one of the big things that
Google+ is trying to do is
encourage really interesting,
thoughtful discussions
and conversations
between people.
And clearly, you've been doing
this for years on your blog.
Clearly, longer than Google+
has been doing it for.
Do you have any
insights on, like,
what tools or key elements
are necessary to promote
deep, thoughtful,
insightful discussion?
JOHN SCALZI: Absolutely I do.
And I'll send you information
about my retainer fee.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Quite honestly, I think
the first thing is
that you have to have-- the
dynamic on my website is,
basically, there's someone
there to lead the discussion.
And that would be
me, saying here
is the topic under discussion.
Here are my thoughts on
this particular topic
under discussion.
The common thread is open.
Make your comments.
People come in to
make the comments.
The person who is refereeing
the conversation-- who
would be me-- makes sure
the ground rules are set,
that people understand the
rules of the road in terms
of the communication, and is
able to direct people when they
get off topic, remove the
trolls when they show up
as they so often do,
and basically make sure
that the conversation
that is being had
is the conversation
that is worth
having on that particular topic.
Now, how do you do that
without going too far
and just basically shutting
down the conversation
or not doing enough
and just basically
having it go discursive
all over the place?
And a lot of it comes down to
practice, practice, practice,
which is the thing that
most people don't have.
You know?
The simple fact of the
matter is that I've
been doing whatever
for close to 16 years--
16 years on the 13th, right?
I been doing this since 1998.
It is paleo as far as the
internet is concerned.
I'm Cretaceous period.
You know?
But because I've been
doing it for a long time,
those rhythms are established.
Most people don't have
the same amount of time
to devote to it as I do.
And they don't have the
same sort of either practice
or rhetorical training.
Because I also have a degree
in philosophy and rhetoric
and stuff like that.
So that a lot of the
detailed instructions
about how to do
this are not there.
And I guess one of the things
that maybe Google+ or anybody
else who wants to foster these
sorts of things can do is, A,
make sure that the people who
are leading the discussions
have a robust set of tools
to deal with discursiveness
so that they actually
own the conversation.
The other thing that I would
say would probably be useful is
somewhere online just say,
how to comment on Google+,
how to have a conversation.
And in one sort of sense, it's
like wow, that seems insulting.
But on the other hand, I
have it up on my website.
It's like, how to
be a good comment.
It's like, are you on topic?
Are you doing what I call the
Libertarian dismount, which
is the thing where
someone-- I'm sorry,
you're clearly
confused about this.
The Libertarian
dismount would be,
like, we're talking
about same-sex marriage.
And someone goes, well,
that's just because, frankly,
the state shouldn't be involved
in the marriage process at all.
And that's fascinating,
but that's not the topic.
You're dragging this
topic over to the thing
you want to talk about, which is
whether or not the state should
be involved with
marriage at all.
Which is not the topic of how
do we deal with the emerging
consensus about
same-sex marriage.
And so, that sort
of dismount into,
I'm uncomfortable
with this topic,
so I really want
to talk about this.
And I'm going to make
you all talk about that,
is something you don't want.
Knowing when to quit.
Knowing when to
have the final word.
Knowing when to walk away.
These are all things that
actually have to be learned.
And some people don't
want to learn those.
Some people do
want to be trolls.
Or some people don't think
that their point of view
is ever possibly wrong.
They don't even mean
it in a malicious way.
They just don't understand
why, through the process
of continually talking
and never shutting up,
you don't eventually come
around their point of view.
Yeah, who knew that
that would happen out
on the internet, where
you don't actually
have that face-to-face
communication?
So a lot of that really
will come down to,
you give the people the tools,
you do as much as you can do.
But sooner or later,
it's the whole thing
of leading the horse to water.
Sooner or later, the horse
either has to drink or not.
And I would say
give as many tools
as you can to allow
people to have
those robust conversations.
Highlight when and where you
see robust conversations.
If you go MetaFilter,
they'll have that-- you know,
Matt Houghey has that
list on the side of,
these are really
cool conversations
that we're having a MetaFilter.
Those are perfect examples.
And you just train people
over the course of time.
It's not something that's
going to immediately happen.
It has to happen over the space
of years and years and years.
And the problem is
that then you always
have new people coming in.
There's an old term
from the Usenet days
that-- what is it-- the
September that never ends?
Which was when, every year,
new kids would come to colleges
and they would get on the
Usenet for the first time.
And then everyone had
to go, oh, it's time
to train them how to use it.
And then AOL-- bless
its heart-- dumped
all it's 20 million people
on the internet all at once.
And it was just
September everywhere.
And so you have a continual
September going on with any
social media, whether it's
Google+ or Twitter or Facebook
or whatever.
Everybody, sooner or
later, cycles through.
And you just have to accept
that that's part of the deal
as well.
That's what I think, and
I'll be sending you a bill.
AUDIENCE: Hey, another
question about audiobooks.
I'm kind of interested in
how the audiobook production
process ties into
writing, if at all.
Does it just come that
you finish a book,
throw it over the
wall to Will Wheaton?
Or is it something
more involved?
Do you think about that
while you're producing?
Does this like
effect your choice
of first versus
third person at all?
JOHN SCALZI: I'm
sorry, I'm stuck
on the image of
me chucking things
over Will Wheaton's wall.
Actually, I will give
an example of something
that I do less
now, because I know
that audio is important to a
large segment of my audience.
Which is dialogue tags.
"Let's go down to the
store," Chris said.
"All right," Christine said.
"Well, make sure that we
get Coca-Cola," Chris said.
And the thing is, is when you're
writing that, the he said,
she said, he said, your
brain filters it out.
Because enough of it, you're
like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The dialogue tag is there
almost in a subliminal way
to let you know who is talking.
So in a printed
medium, the fact that I
put said at the
end of everything
doesn't really affect things.
In audiobook, it gets
astoundingly monotonous.
And I didn't-- people started
saying this to me once
Will's versions of
stuff of mine took off.
And they're like,
you use said a lot.
And I'm like, no, I don't.
I don't really.
And then I listened to-- I
was listening to "Red Shirts."
and there was like a
part in chapter two.
It's like, blah,
blah, blah, Doll said.
Blah, blah, blah,
blah, Hanson said.
I was like, who is this idiot?
Who is the idiot
who wrote this crap?
I need to talk to him.
Because what works in one
medium doesn't necessarily
work in another medium.
So for "Lock In,"
because I knew that it
was going to be done
in audio, I took out
I would say, probably 30%
40% of the dialogue tags.
Where if it's just
like two characters
having a conversation, it'll
be Chris said, John said.
And then the next
time I go to Chris,
it doesn't have a
dialogue tag because that
is the logical place
for that to be going.
And so, in that
respect, yes absolutely.
That is one example
of how my writing has
accommodated this other medium.
Now, whether it's enough for
people who really dislike
the fact that I use
that dialogue tag,
we'll have to see.
But yeah, you are
aware, no matter
what you're doing,
where your audience is
and what their expectations are.
And to the extent that
it doesn't actually
compromise your story
or compromise what
is that you want to do, you
want to accommodate that,
because you want them
to buy your stuff so you
could make your
mortgage payment.
So frankly, I was
happy to do that
and to incorporate that in.
And there are other
things that probably I
do now that I'm not aware of.
But since I've been
listening to Will and Amber
and William Dufris, who does the
"Old Man's War" stuff and Tavia
Gilbert who did "Zoe's
Tale", listening to them
do my stories, you
definitely soak that in
and you find out new
things about yourself
as a writer because of it.
Come on down.
AUDIENCE: You've talked
online before about that you
deliberately make
your novels very,
like, approachable to readers.
And it's definitely
something I've noticed
and you're sort of
the author I recommend
to non-science fiction
fans just to kind of get
into science fiction.
Do you think science
fiction needs
to do more of that-- needs to
grow beyond its genre roots?
And where is that
line kind of blurring
at the moment, between things
that sit in the science fiction
section of the bookstore
versus a general novel?
JOHN SCALZI: I do think science
fiction could do with some more
sort of gateway science fiction.
I'm torn, because in
one sort of sense,
there is not a huge amount
of gateway science fiction
out there, which is great
for me because I write it.
So I end up being
recommended a lot.
It was like, what should I read?
I don't read a lot
of science fiction.
Scalzi.
Anybody else?
No.
So that's awesome.
On the other hand, it's
not necessarily very good
for the genre.
The thing about it
is that if it has
to be working on
all sorts of levels.
You need people like me who are
writing the gateway fiction.
It's kind of going,
hey, just one hit.
It'll be fine.
And the next thing
you know-- you know.
Then you need people who are
doing the next level of science
fiction, where the water
is a little deeper,
things are a little
more complex.
And then, eventually
you lead them
down the path that takes them
to Charlie Strauss and China
Mieville, right?
And then, once they're there,
they're trapped, right?
They will never escape
that hole-- the Venus fly
trap of science
fiction and fantasy.
But I think it needs to
operate on all those levels.
You can't just have everything
be open and accessible and fun,
because then the people who
are really dyed-in-the-wool,
heavy science fiction fans
are just going to sit there
and roll their eyes.
There are people who won't
read me because they're like,
Scalzi, take off
the training wheels.
And that's perfectly reasonable.
It's like, I'm not
writing for them.
But there are other
people who, you
know-- if I tried to hand my
mother-in-law-- who I love
and who reads Julie Garwood and
Nora Roberts-- hand her Charlie
Strauss or hand her China
Mieville-- both of whom
are writers that I
think are fabulous
and have created some of
the best science fiction
work of the new
century-- she would
like read for maybe
about five pages
and she would set it down
and never do that again.
You have to have all
that work in all levels
if the field is
going to be healthy.
So I do think we need more
people doing stuff like me.
We need more people
doing stuff like Charlie
and more people doing stuff
like Kameron Hurley, who
is doing some fantasy right
now which is very complex.
We need more people like
her doing stuff like that.
Ann Leckie, who just
won every single award
imaginable for
"Ancillary Justice,"
we need more of people like
her who are taking space opera
and just basically breaking
it apart and putting it
back together again
in new formats.
We need more of
everything is basically
my feeling about science
fiction and fantasy.
So hopefully we're
in the place where
we'll get some more of that.
AUDIENCE: So, I love the
"Old Man's War" universe,
and I look forward to
more books in that genre.
But how, as an
author, do you decide
when to continue
expanding the universe?
And when you kind of don't
have anything new to say?
JOHN SCALZI: That's actually
a really good question,
because there is that tension.
Because "Old Man's War"
is very successful.
You've done very well
for me, thank you.
I will sit in my hot
tub in honor of you.
We did just buy a
hot tub, by the way.
And it's ridiculous.
It is a ridiculous hot tub.
I was telling them
earlier, it's a hot tub--
it's like an RV of hot tubs.
It's just like it seats seven.
You can have a TV in
it, it has chilled
drinks, all this sort of stuff.
And it's the thing that--
you know that old story,
if you give a mouse
a cookie, it's
going to want a glass of milk?
If you get yourself
a hot tub, you're
going to want a gazebo
for the hot tub.
It's a money pit.
So I'm very excited
about the hot tub.
So please buy more books
is what I'm trying to say.
But no, here's the tension.
On one hand, I could,
quite literally,
write an "Old Man's War"
book and then something else,
and then another "Old Man's
War" book and something else,
and another "Old Man's War"
book, until the cows come home.
And a lot of people
would buy them.
And they would get
to the point where
they're like, oh, you know, "Old
Man's War" 17, whatever it is.
They'd be like,
oh, you know, it's
not as good as they were
when he started out.
But, I guess it's OK.
You know?
And I don't want to be that guy.
For one thing, because
if I'm bored writing,
which I would get bored writing
if I just kept hacking them
out, you're going
to be bored reading.
And you might buy
them out of habit,
but I don't want you to
buy them out of habit.
I want you to buy them
because you're like,
holy crap, this out, this
is new, and I need it now.
I want to actually
want to get it,
as opposed to feel sort
of a moral obligation.
Kind of the way you
felt about watching
episode three of the Star
Wars prequel trilogy.
It's like, I've invested
this much time, off we go.
Are you Vader, yet?
You know what I mean?
You were there.
Yeah, and I don't want that.
I want you to
actually be excited
about every new episode.
And sometimes that means
actually stepping away.
Like, I did an arc that
started with "Old Man's War"
and ended with "Last
Colony" and "Zoe's Tale."
It told the story of John
Perry and his family, right?
That was a complete art.
And then, when that was
done, I took five years off
of the "Old Man's War" series.
And part of the
reason for that was I
didn't know where
else to go with it.
I mean, their story was
told, I put the universe
in a precarious position, but
I didn't know what that meant.
And so, I went off
and did other things
while it was rolling
around in my brain.
And then I became interested
right around the same time
that the folks at
Tor were like, we
would like to do this episodic
project where we do everything
electronically in
a serial fashion.
I was like, well,
interestingly enough,
I was thinking of doing
a series of short stories
with these characters.
Why don't we combine
those together?
And that's how that showed up.
The second "Human
Division" book,
which I'm working on right now--
which will be out next year--
is going to be kind of in the
same sort of boat of things.
But ultimately,
what's going to happen
with that is, when those
two books are done,
I will probably step away from
the "Old Man's War" universe
again, because I've
got to figure out
what's going to happen next.
And I would rather take
the time to figure out
what's happening next then
to just again hack it out.
The good news is that apparently
you guys do by my other books.
This actually just landed on the
New York Times hardcover best
seller list.
So I'm like, yes.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
I was like, wow, what a relief.
But it seems like you
guys are willing to let
me do other things,
which is the other trap.
Because the question
becomes, do people love you--
this is the author neurotic
thing-- do they love me for me
or do they love
me for my series?
Right?
Like, if I write something else,
does that something else become
like, the band
that goes, "This is
the title track
of our new album."
And everybody goes
out to go pee.
Right?
Play the hits, which would be
the "Old Man's War" series.
So fortunately, it
seems like you're
willing to let me
do other things
and I really appreciate that.
But it is a consideration.
I do have a mortgage to pay.
I do have a daughter who's going
to go through college one day.
I want to retire one day.
All this sort of stuff.
I have a hot tub.
So all of these things
conspire to what
things are going
to be commercial
and what things
are going to work.
But you know, for me, I do
have the luxury of saying,
I'll get back to it
when I get back to it.
So I might, after the
end of this next book,
get back to the "Old Man's
War" five years down the line,
10 years down the
line, wherever.
But when I get
back to it, it will
be because I want to
be there as opposed
to I feel like I
have to be there.
And I think this should
be the last question,
and then we'll get
to the signing stuff.
AUDIENCE: Can you share details
of your non-book projects
that you're working on?
JOHN SCALZI: Non-book projects?
TV, TV, you want to
know about the TV?
OK, I have two TV projects.
One is "Old Man's War,"
which is going to be at SyFy.
Which apparently fills a
lot of people with terror.
They're like, SyFy,
they do wrestling.
They don't do science fiction.
No, they actually have started
doing science fiction again.
They've got "The Expanse"
series by James S A Corey,
"The Magicians" by Lev
Grossman, yeah, right?
Yeah.
I'm excited about it, too, sir.
And then, of course,
my book series as well.
So they seem to be going
all-in about actually living up
to their network name.
That's going to be positive.
"Redshirts" has
been optioned by FX
as a mini series, which is
kind of cool because they've
been doing really well
with the miniseries.
They've just got
nominated for-- and I
think have won-- quite a few
Emmys for their "Fargo" series,
as an example of that.
And those are at the
writing stage right now.
I've met with the writers for
the "Old Man's War" series.
Which is also another
reason why I'm
OK to step back, because in the
meantime, while I'm thinking
about where it goes next, you'll
have these guys dribbling out
new episodes of whatever's going
on in the "Old Man's War" world
and that will be kind of fun.
And it's fascinating,
because, you know,
it's a completely
different medium.
You understand when you go
into that the book is not
going to be the TV
series, and the TV series
is not going to be the book.
And the changes that
they have to make
because the storytelling
is different.
The fact that they
actually have to work
within certain
budgetary constraints,
and so on and so forth.
And just the way
that that all works.
And people are like,
are you worried
about them changing your books?
And I'm like, no,
because they're not
going to change books.
The books are over here.
They will always
remain the same.
I own the copyright on those,
they ain't changing, right?
But what they do do will
be kind of interesting.
Now, if they're successful,
it doesn't matter.
Because what they do to the
series in some sort of way,
because the books will take off.
Like, you may have heard of
this guy, George Martin, right?
He's got this little series on
HBO called "Game of Thrones."
His books are just
this huge clot
at the top of the best
seller lists in paperback.
It's like every
month, in and out,
you've got all like--
four out of the six
books-- I think there's
six, how many books now?
Five?
You guys would know.
Four out of the five--
there's always right up there
at the top.
And the thing is that, the
fact that they can just
wait until season six or
whatever or season five comes
out doesn't stop the
books from selling.
So I'm kind of looking
forward to that, you know?
Because then I will take this
hot tub that I just bought
and I will fill
it full of money.
I'll just sit there and
rub the money on me.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Just like that.
So that will be really positive.
So that's one thing.
I'm also working on a video
game called "Midnight Star"
with Industrial Toys, which is
a first-person-shooter that's
designed for tablets.
So can play a
first-person-shooter literally
with one hand.
So on hand holding the
tablet, the other one
killing all the aliens
and stuff like that.
One of the principals
of Industrial Toys
is Alex Seropian, who co-founded
Bungie and co-created Halo.
So when he called me
up and was like, hey,
would you like to do
this video game with me?
I was like, that seems
an acceptable risk.
So that will
actually hopefully be
out in the next couple months.
And I've seen it
and I've played it.
And it's a hell of a lot of fun.
And that's what I'm
going to say about that.
Well, we are at the
two o'clock hour.
And what I will do now is I
will go to the back of the room
and I will happily
sign your books.
Thank you all for
coming and spending
your free hour with me.
[APPLAUSE]